all right we are are live for the
February AMA that is ask me anything
session hopefully everybody can hear all
right I'm getting things set up here on
my end and I do that let me say a big
thank you to all of my patreon
supporters we've got 95 at this point
hoping for getting to a hundred fairly
soon they're the ones who make this this
sort of activity possible
you know carving out time from from my
day and supporting all the work that I
do let me get myself set up here with
the chat thing there's always a little
bit of finagling things in YouTube there
we go
so looks like I can I can actually see
it on the page we're opening and I've
got a question already from somebody and
it's do a watch dank memes so the answer
to that would be no in part because I
thought dank was just a way of
describing memes I thought it was sort
of a term that people used in the meme
producing community for saying that they
particularly liked certain memes I don't
actually I don't know enough about meme
culture to really have much to say about
classification so if I imagine there
must be a video channel out there called
dank memes or something like that so
that's no I don't I don't actually why
to that I don't watch a lot of videos in
part because I don't have the time to
and you know I produce a lot of video
content but that takes a lot of time
each of the five each of the half-hour
Haegele videos this takes about you know
between editing putting all the stuff
together
planning it thinking out what I want to
say takes about five hours for read to
those and some of the alright there's a
lot of questions already rolling in so
let me quit blathering about that John
Fisher asks what are your views on the
ethics euthanasia and abortion do you
think either of these should or continue
to be legal so think that you know III I
think that there could be some
situations in which you know from sort
of a consequentialist perspective it
could actually make sense to say that
that abortion should be the case you
know should be provided I think that in
a lot of cases that's not actually the
case you know we're kind of the same
thing with euthanasia we're kind of
boxed into this corner in the West where
we decide everything on this vocal level
in terms of legality and that's where a
lot of these debates take place rather
than and you know you might say on the
ground where were they taking place and
where it works you know it's kind of hit
or miss so yeah that's probably enough
of an answer
can I please give a lecture on
hans-georg gadamer so you know I've got
a lot of other stuff to do I like
gadamer but other things slated I do you
know accept commissions for doing videos
with which means that I put some of my
projects on hold and focus on what what
somebody's actually commissioning me
wants me to do but but I don't I don't
think there's any guy out of Myr stuff
coming up anytime soon and Parks them so
far because I need to do although you
know giving a lecture that that's that's
that's feasible
ha she are asked what are your views on
affirmative action or reservation so I
should say that reservation is another
way of talking about it as far as I know
it is mostly used in Indian context you
know what we call set aside that's right
I think that in it's one of those things
where it can be useful but only for a
certain amount of time and the problem
is is that once affirmative action
structures are created they tend to be
not viewed as a temporary you know fix
for clear injustice and and deprivation
taken for granted as like a right you
know by various people I know this is a
big problem in Indy yeah where for a
10-year period and they've been extended
an extended extended and they probably
won't go away and we have similar things
happening here in the United States in
terms of affirmative action as well but
I also think it's important to look at
these things on a case-by-case basis I
don't have any intrinsic objection to
firma say all right so let me thing
jumps around a little bit when I screw
role Richard at vice you can give young
people so that's a good one because I
personally you know looking at the
situation that I've grown up in I'm you
know now a middle played may and ratio I
think that things are much harder for
many young people in what we call here
in the United States
it's the Millennial Generation and
Generation Y and you know in part
because over time you know the Boomers
really were the apex they a access to
cheap healthcare to cheap education to
cheap loans housing
and cost that my generation got hit with
some really difficult stuff and I think
it's even worse for the present
generations and we could talk about in
all different causes for this so there's
there's some real challenges ahead that
it's important to figure out what you
can use so that you don't become
despondent or despair and you know so
you can make it through each day and I
think philosophy can help with that I
doubt that you know much academic
philosophy it's going to help
particularly with that but a lot of you
know philosophy is a way of life I think
can can help you with with those
4-channel and sort of make distinctions
when when you need to and engage and you
know practical reasoning that leads to
good decision making oh here's a good
one from Linden do you feel your
background in philosophy and rhetoric
critical thinking arms you in any way
against persuasion salesmanship shilling
and Cod philosophy and so on yeah it
does it also makes me it makes me a bad
client when it comes to psychotherapy
because I have a hard time going in and
dealing with the average therapist who
you know studied a few things here and
there and has got a lot of practical
hours and deals with people who
generally want things explained to them
and haven't ever you know read any any
theory and you know like you know just
the other day I was actually in a
nervous office and he was recommending
something to me and I was saying you're
getting that out of Gatlin right I've
already you know I get boy you're that's
not helpful here you know and so that's
that makes it very tough to find someone
to work with but it also yeah does army
against sales many sort of pitches and
I'm gonna take a little bit of time here
just talk about a bit of digression make
a bit of digression ha I can
on like in the last week so I've had I
always get pitches from everybody liked
it LinkedIn and other things people who
want me to work with become heart
remember join you know system or they
want to provide me with business
coaching and I find that much of what
those people are is play but they've got
these talking points in their head and
they don't really know how to go beyond
that and so you know all I'll hear
somebody you know for example being part
of a new streaming network and I was
like that you know this is really cool
for gamers I was just going to work for
philosophy and the person did not have
any answers at all instead I got answers
about like what the founders were I even
went so far as to like give him a schema
and say here's how you could make an
argument to me
I'm just looking for you to fill in the
content and this person could not do it
because they didn't have you know on the
one hand they I think they didn't have
the the information they hadn't done
their research on my channel and on the
other hand I think they would had that
habit of mind of just not going beyond
that I got pitched on LinkedIn somebody
LinkedIn connected with me and wanted to
pitch me some coaching stuff and then
backpedaled once they realize that I do
coaching because again hadn't done their
research you know I got two different
pitches to belong to you know networks
for philosophers working or PhDs working
outside of academia aces I was like I
don't see how this is actually valuable
for me sounds like you're doing in
effect multi-level marketing and you
want me to be in what we call your
downline so yeah you know being able to
to analyze the things effectively and
ask the right questions really does arm
you against a lot of the BS the human -
alright so that's a long digression on
that let me answer Francis's question
why aren't more philosophers also
mystics so you got to be careful there
because mystic means a lot of different
things
according to somebody like Bertrand
Russell you know who totally abused the
term like many British philosophers of
his era did this person is a mystic this
person is a mystic really in and on a
strict speaking
it is a mistic unless you think that
there's some sort of ineffable reality
that you engage through perhaps
contemplation and or meditation or or
through action or love or something like
that and that that you know surpasses
philosophy or you know surpasses the the
realm of the comprehensible in general
let's say I mean you could ask the same
question why aren't more literary
figures mystics why aren't more
historians mystics why aren't more
sociologists mystics and the answer I
thought is
once you go the path of saying that
there's something and it's absolutely
important it puts everything in
perspective and you just can't say
anything about it or you can you know
maybe have some metaphors about it
you're kind of stepping outside of the
game other philosophers can legitimately
look at you and say yeah I'm not buying
it and I myself am very distrustful in
part because of personal experience of
people who make appeals to you know
mystical States or stuff like that I'm
not saying I think it's all [ __ ] but
I would say that you know half of the
people that I've encountered that are
that are talking about this sort of
stuff it is [ __ ] when they're
talking about it and so I'm very careful
about about sort of thing and I I think
that you know there's an argument that
you can make that that oh you know the
lit of reality like that I mean Plato's
gesturing at that the form of the good
you know think about all all this sort
of neo platonic and contemplation and
reaching something beyond just the
intellect that's all you know cool but
[Music]
it's you know it's hard to get other
people to to buy into that I'd say so
andrew has a comment I really appreciate
your series on the worlds of speculative
fiction always makes my day thank you
yeah that's that's actually turned out
to be quite a fun thing
we originally just envisioned it for a
year you know so for those who don't
know it so it's it's a series that I do
with a local library that way which is
which is West out in you know the
suburbs of Milwaukee and we've got a
good group of people who show up you
know engage in conversation sometimes
all of them have read the text sometimes
only some of them have tried to bring
you know some some useful discussion
about world building philosophical
themes the biography of the purse excuse
to indulge myself and some guilty
pleasure reading in science fiction
fantasy or cyberpunk a couple other
genres as well and so oh it's it's a you
know taking on a lot life of its s for
it which you can find in the reason IO
Academy I think I've got it linked to in
all the videos in that series you can
click on that it's free class actually
you can sign up for it I'm still
building it out though alright
Leviathan what is the difference between
Spinoza and Hegel's understanding of
determination is negation simply put
Spinoza's as static and Hegel's is
dynamic
you know Spinoza's is largely you know
abstracting away from history or stuff
like that although you know there's room
for thinking historically within a spend
mystic perspective it's just that you
know you know like teyla tracked honest
halo echo politicus and things like that
it just isn't you know
Haga deliver thinking in terms of
determination as negation but he's
thinking through nagae he shouldn't in
an in a different way and tying it
directly to historical development so
I'd say that's I mean there's a lot more
to be said about that but um that's uh
papa met - who's your favorite
philosopher that is one I can't answer
because I don't don't have a favorite
philosopher if I have a list of people
who I really like and I keep going back
to over and over again I think that
every one of them I don't get enough
time to read all all of their stuff
again and but I I don't I don't actually
have a favorite I'll tell you you know
the people that I really enjoy just sort
of running through and of course you
know Plato Aristotle
when it comes to the Stoics I really
like Epictetus a lot although you know
Seneca he's kind of growing it and they
really like Cicero I enjoy reading
Augustine but I probably would say I
like Louie theist
the man some more
but every once in a while I find myself
enjoying it but but not not quite so
much I really enjoy you know being dicks
Hume is another favorite and these
notice these are people I tend to not
agree with
where's Hegel even though Hegel was very
drunk
I like the scope of his thoughts
Nietzsche
you know Kierkegaard
Gabrielle Marcel big fans of them mock
Schaller Dietrich von Hildebrand you
know Alistair McIntyre is a living
philosopher who I'm a big fan of I mean
I just go on and on and on right and so
I think that's not very helpful so I'm
gonna stop oh here's a great question by
flea-bitten why to colleges teach Marx
but not Rand so it depends on the
college right and and we've got to
always be careful about generalizing
about the American system because we're
this weird patchwork of all these
different colleges and universities well
not like most countries that have a
national system but it is true that that
you're not going to see a lot of
teaching of Rann except in business
departments where where you often find a
lot of people liking them that said I've
actually know a few Randy ins in my time
some of whom did in fact each Rand and I
actually taught Rand in ethics classes
not as versed but as a great
representative of egoism but in
the the idea among a lotta mix is Rand
is just terrible philosophy and look at
the deplorable people all that that read
her so why would we even want to bother
with that and and I've had some eyebrows
raised when people find out that I
actually did teacher and you know but I
teach everybody right III teach a broad
spectrum of people very new of whom I
actually am in anything like three
quarters agreement with now why do
people teach mark that Marxism they
actually taught that moon there's a lot
of references to Marx but I don't know
that many people who actually know their
marks and teach their marks but but you
know oh it's fair to say that the
Academy is much more comfortable with
thought that's that's on the left then
thought that's on the right uh you know
that's that's the way it works I will
say that you know from reports that I'm
getting Rand is starting into Kansas
interestingly enough so it's you know
it's worth actually reading her she's a
terrible historian of philosophy you
know just ignore every or take with a
grain of salt everything she tells you
about you know everybody from Plato on
but you know her thoughts are
interesting and they're well it so if
you want and same thing with Marx I mean
you know Marx
he's very unfair to most of the people
that he criticizes but he's got some you
know some interesting thoughts that are
worth taking a look at as well hush-hush
Shearer asks my views on nationalism
well there's all different kinds of
nationalism for talking about the sort
of you know my nation right into raw
I'll admit in the past I've been
nostalgic for that sort of thing you
know when I was in high school I'll tell
you a story here that again a bit of a
digression so when I was in high school
I was reading a lot of social theory and
you know I was also reading kind of
widely in the history of religions and I
was quite frustrated by the society that
I was living in so we're talking about
the 1980s I plan to go in the military
you know and I was you know pretty rough
and tough kid in many respects I was
getting in trouble for getting in fights
and and stuff like that and although I I
you know just kind of coasted through
through school and I got put in the AP
like American mind class and the teacher
for the history class he was a real jerk
terrible guy he had us write essays news
were right so predictably enough most of
the inning any laid it out like you know
we've got you know radical liberal
conservative reactionary and so most of
the girls were liberal almost the boys
were conservative and I began my essay
by saying you know I would say that I'm
drawing my political depart from
Napoleon benedito Mussolini and I forget
who the third person I know Oh from
Clausewitz yeah and you know I proceeded
to outline this this thing it was
essentially sort of a you know a fash
just perspective I'm not a racist person
because there's a difference in national
socialism and fascism that that we
respect in fascist studies or at least
some of us do and I was invited to get
up in front of the class and read it and
the reason I was invited to so everyone
could you know excoriate me for being
such terrible person and then there was
one guy who came up to me who is now a
raging right winger total reactionary
and he was like you know I didn't want
to say anything in class but I think
you're right and I and I sort of
revulsion towards him because I figured
out very quickly that he was for what I
was talking about but for very very
different reasons I wanted an end if
that's conflict I wanted an end to to
sort of you know struggles between
nations I had this sort of
P realistic idea that I was laying out
and keep in mind I was 16 years old at
the time and so there you know there's
different kinds of nationalism and I
understand some of the attractions to to
that you know if his first inaugural
speech he's essentially banning speech
he's outlining this sort of like we're
gonna get rid of all these conflicts and
take care of everybody by America first
right and that's a perennial l'heure
I think that it can be you know history
Jonah a very bad thing when it gets
misappropriated and it almost always
does get misappropriated so I'm not a
big fan of nationalism anymore you know
when I when I hear a new model armies
you know my my people right or wrong
there's something aiming so I know that
that temptation anyway that's that's
probably enough about that
scrubby Bismarck's get right and what is
not
that'll have to be very brief so I'll
say right now that my very favorite
piece by Marx is one that most marked -
which is the eighteenth Brumaire of
napoleon bonaparte right which is about
i start of tracing out how something
almost like fascism develops because of
class conflicts not being will work
through properly and not moving in
towards the right thing this line about
you know at first things are repeated
things are repeated in history you know
I think forget exactly the wording you
know first as a drama that is a farce
right and it shows a lot of insight into
those things and I think Marx is also
right about the notion of alienation I
think he got some things right you know
the historical determinism man Marx just
quit believing in that stuff you know
over a century ago when things didn't
turn out the way that they're being
predict right so you know there there
there we go
all right canal points out that ran
didn't ever published anything in a
peer-reviewed niche
well did he yeah maybe he did but
neither did neither did Marx
neither did you know most sigh I don't I
don't know that that's actually
important
Wilhelm have you read Stephen Hicks
explaining modernism if so what's your
take I haven't read and I actually you
know I've been hosted by the Institute
for ethics and entrepreneurship to come
down to Rockford to give talks about
stoicism they met Hicks there yet cuz I
always deal with my former classmate and
colleague Matt Flay on who's a santiana
scholar
cool guy but I haven't read I haven't
read hiks hiks book so I can't really
say any anything about it at this point
um oops just skip through bunch of them
let me scroll a bit oh here's a good
question from the all qui RF 44 how
would a stoic act if they were in the
situation of the Florida shooting so
this is you know the Florida shooting
and there's gonna be many many many more
of these situations until something
changes here in America and it's gonna
have to be some sort of radical change
I'll tell you too again I'll sort of
open up to you I've been talking with my
wife about this she's kind of my self
funding board or to crap and with exact
you know I come from a family of gun
nutters people who are all about all the
government guns I grew up in rural
Wisconsin you know I was in the army
I fired weapons III understand
Oh Oh late old buddy nobody in the
United States should have an assault
weapon I don't even want the cops to
have them you know quite frankly there
are some extremely controlled things but
no civilian needs to have that sort of
crap in order to feel safe or have fun
or do whatever any of the arguments that
you know any of these sort of weapons
can be used for hunting I got an uncle
who used to hunt deer with a pistol well
but he's you know a guy who actually
understands guns he's not you know a
play around kinda guy so we're gonna
have this sort of stuff going on for a
long time
and here's my sort of inflammatory state
bomb confiscated a ball quite frankly
it's not gonna happen but I'm I'm at the
point where I'm I'm fed up enough with
the totally inaction on this this issue
and the NRA just essentially funneling
tons of money into you know these these
that's pockets you know I don't know
what else will be done there's gonna be
apparently there's gonna be a national
walkout day for teachers I think that's
a great idea I'm gonna support that
anyway back to the stoic question so how
it how the stoic can handle this oh it's
it's a tough situation because you know
by the time that happens law and order
has broken yeah you know used to rasaan
but you know what you ought to do is is
get yourself and whoever you're
responsible for safe as quickly as you
can
and then sir we're training them I think
the coach who threw himself in front of
the students was displaying courage I
you don't have to be a stoic to do that
you get to be people who who stressed
the need for that sort of thing
courage is doing is taking RIT
looks like that and saving children is
is a good reason for that so very
difficult topic and I don't know that I
have anything really helpful else to say
about that canal ask when you're done
with hate deal would you do a serie
maybe I mean those yeah those probably
would be good to do see here here's
something about Lacan if you want to
read Lacan and make sense out of him
don't read the recreate first read some
of the seminars because the seminars
make more sense in the acree Lacan who's
a brilliant guy and I really like it for
a lot of reasons is acting like a jerk
he's kind of sticking it to everybody
showing everybody how clever he is you
know putting as many references as he
possibly can and plays on words and
there's really no good reason for it I
mean people try to give you know good
reasons for it there isn't any good
reason for that sort of thing you know
his ideas are worth thinking about
that's not actually a text that I
thought about giving the half-hour Hagel
treatment too but I could be I could be
convinced I'll tell you this before I
jump into any big book I'm gonna have to
set up some we make putting that much
effort in a very very you know or some
other crowdfunding thing I've been
considering doing you know high degrees
being in time starts being in nothing in
this arithmetic physics Plato's Republic
I can only do one big book in it you
know I am doing some smaller ones like I
did you know that whole series on epic
tape design create and equations going
through it line by line looking at you
know the English translation the French
translation because you didn't write in
French in the lat so a follow-up
question from pancake I think when will
he
he'll be done well that's kind of good
news before two more years because I'm
now in the 500s there's about 800
paragraphs and making good progress
getting six videos done per month so
yeah that that that works
let's see Lee will you ever talk about
Buddhism or the bhagavad-gita mm-hmm you
know I do talk about them with some of
my clients I do preparation for the
Indians civil service exam which a big
component on Indian philosophy on
Western philosophy there's an ethics
component social and political
philosophy component and these things
comes and I talk about you know teyla's
you know treaties and in all sorts of
other things as well but I'm not I don't
feel myself to have the sadie's in part
because I you know I don't read Sanskrit
for one thing all right and I don't read
Pali if I want oh when
Hegel's puzzle it out you know you might
say well then why the hell'd you do
anything on Dostoevsky or kick the guard
but you don't know Danish well but but I
I trust the Hong translations and so
yeah I I don't I don't know if all if
all do stuff on that again that that
would require me to have more time on my
hands so a lot of this a lot of the
answer to these things is you know when
I reach a sufficient level of support
because you know I don't have backing
from a school or a governmental agency
or something like that it's it's viewers
essentially and subscribers who wing of
what I do the other stuff that I do to
earn a living you know the tutorials
coaching consulting thing all of that
that that's that's a bit different but
there are people are like you know
paying for that so
I will say this though it says
took religions and so you know I was
reading a lot of stuff always in
translation and of course and then I got
to teach you know when I was teaching in
the prison world religions was a staple
class so I would continually be adding
more and more to it and then I got it
again
to teach a couple of upper look classes
in in religious studies on Eastern
religions as well which is you know a
lot of philosophical workers as well
that was fun
Ashley asked can I recommend any ethics
critical thinking and philosophy book
for toddlers children and tweens I I
can't that because I don't read much
secondary Lit I have it and I don't do
much of that for for kids I'm usually
just reading you know stuff that people
are sending to me are the unnatural and
unnecessary desires such as for wealth
power good reputation fame which are
based on groundless opinion and
Epicureanism or empty opinion kano
stokes yeah synonymous to the external
factors in stoicism i'd say similar but
not the same there's different analyses
being given and there's a different
basis for for how this is being puzzled
out and I'd say you know if you want to
get a good comparative like discussion
which is at times unfair to Epicureanism
but is presenting it very well
read on the ends here's a good one lucre
do I know any polish philosophers yes
and as a matter of fact did at an
interest and QH I think I butchered his
name as I usually have to ask him what
every
and I see em he and I he's in he's one
of the modern stoicism team and so with
him just done under conversations that
matter I think or ideas that matter he's
a cool guy
young guy just just had a kid does a lot
of work on stoicism there have I known
any other polish philosophers I've met a
few here and sometimes like in the Mac
and Association International
Association for Mac interion
inquiry I think it's yeah it's me
International Society for MacIntyre an
inquiry mathematician when I as one of
my math teachers when I was at Lakeland
College she came in like the two years
before I left and I took I took some
classes with her and she actually had
some really interesting speculation
she's about numbers and you know with
any of the YouTube discussions between
people like sam Harris and Jordan
Peterson know like I said at the
beginning I don't really watch a lot of
other people's videos and part because I
don't have time and you know I've heard
about their their discussion people have
referenced it a lot and I you know I
guess I should stay on top of that sort
of thing because we're all kind of
working in the same niche of public
intellectual but I see what I had
different than what they do
so gunam lately I've begun to consider
language and obstacle to knowledge I
feel myself drawn away from
argumentation and what he suggests it's
always okay to take a break for a while
but you're never gonna get away from
language probably the issue you know
feeling like everybody's arguments are
kind of BS or a groundless but you know
it's all we is logos speech and reason
to work with which doesn't preclude by
the way the you know the
motions their affections so very ask any
views in antinatalism pessimism cosmic
nihilism I'm not a proponent of any of
them I and I you know I don't buy you
into any of them Oh Oh Jonathan asks an
interesting very practical question I
save fifty to seventy-five percent of my
income um hoping one day I'll have
enough money to take it off if what are
you and people in chat think of this
well that's amazing that you can even do
that to begin with
I've lived very frugally at many and I
actually lived pretty frugal II now you
know the biggest expenses is probably
living here or in the middle of
Milwaukee I'm I'm a fan of saving 75
percent that that's just an incredible
yeah you actually can manage to do that
and and not you know break any any you
know ethical rules or district as you
want and it makes sense to me
you know money is is something that that
useful no don't have any of it but you
know you want to keep it in proper
perspective so I yeah I don't see
anything wrong with doing that you'll
probably find that you want other things
that involve other people with that
money in that retreat anyway I'm gonna
skip down a bit
Derek okay ask service tree on John
Locke and the aftermath of the English
Civil Wars I am doing one this year yes
I do one ancient one medieval one early
modern and late modern so this year it
is uh we just did the Cicero and then
I'm doing Augustine and that and and
then we're finishing up with Albert
Camus
let's see Kenai asks regarding say that
Kant is fiction I don't know I haven't I
haven't imagined that's probably coming
from the history of philosophy which I
haven't looked at at for quite a while
because OBE ad in parts that it's it's
not worth returning to so I don't know
why he says that Kant is fiction but you
know or if he in Jonathan any thoughts
on Alan Watts
I mean a good popular bird faithful you
know interpretations of non-western
philosophy but he's a lot of fun you
know I think that you know like a lot of
people in his generation it you know
non-western philosophy was cushion to
him and it opened up all sorts of
interesting doors but you know he's uh I
start like Will Durant or Bertrand
Russell in the history of Western
philosophy
[Music]
oh you can read them just take it with a
grain of salt what do you think is worth
taking out of Humes an inquiry
concerning the president making any
video that text I've considered it but
you know there's like considering in the
sense of like wouldn't it be fun to do
something like you know getting into the
planning stage and I'm nowhere near that
I'd to do a few things on him
if religion I did a video on that a long
time ago so a lot of the inquiry are
concerning the principles of morals is
actually reword on book three of the the
treatise on human nature which is a
better work I think I think then both of
the inquiries in part because it's an
attempt to be sort of systematic about
about the human project
I mean what's interesting in there you
know the discussions of justice whether
there's a social contract or not the
whole notion that it's really you know
the human and the nature of the human
being that we can rely upon I mean if
you think about Hume right Hume you've
got that like the you know the the I way
is ID and you know causality doesn't
really exist and you would think that
Hume would be saying well anything kind
of goes but no he says there is a human
nature that we can own copy much the
same everywhere if you take that out of
the picture Hume becomes way a more skep
then yeah so yeah that's kind of cool
oh wow Linden asked what common
strumming and annoys do the most which
one are you totally sick of but that's
tough that's sort of like asking me
who's my favorite philosopher right
there's so mad at me that that
personally annoys me when people are
like oh you know you academics you don't
really understand you know how things
work in the real world and you're like
first off dummy I I'm not in traditional
academia and haven't been for a long
time so nice job on doing your research
before you open your mouth and second
academics live in the real world just
like everybody else we all have you know
the same mortgages taxes
PARP payments you know getting's in
school you know as the thing goes we put
our pants on one leg at a time and so
the times you know our foot gets caught
in the pan that's just like the regular
people who think that somehow you're
closer to reality or something like that
you know I mean that's I see people do
is I'm gonna hammer them right but I see
people doing that a lot and they do it
like when you've called them on their BS
like they put forth something I knew
that happens a lot like stoah stoic
things right where somebody will put
forth some really off-the-wall
interpretation I'll be like listen act
opposite of that here's the video on it
little bit oh you academics and I'll be
like you know good luck with your
studies it's for I'm not gonna bother
with conversation with you you know it's
even funnier when it happens to Donald
who is you know a psychotherapist so
he's not an academic at all neither
actually about I would say a third of
the people in the modern stoicism
project are definitely not and not
academics you know some of them are you
know really high level academics like
Chris Gill but yeah you know who you get
involved in a discussion about something
that has to do with philosophy and
somebody who actually knows something
about it says something to you it's a
good thing you're right off so that's
that's one for me I would I would say oh
sandy has a greater would you consider
it on the philosophy with an Alice in
Wonderland I've never thought of that
but that would actually be a lot of fun
I
he have discussions of the Sherlock
Holmes stories and actually you know
what else would make kind of cool with
that would be like the channel sturgeon
but Alice in Wonderland yeah that could
be really interesting again that's a
matter finding the time to do these
things so I don't know I get a what I
actually got to sit down is do a sit
down and like think about all the cool
projects I would like to be working and
get people to to fund these these
projects to make it possible so there's
a question can and what does it matter
and how does it help a person if they
understand the difference between
idealism and materialism or rationalism
and Pyrrhus ism or determinism and
indeterminism what does anything matter
I mean it's nice to know reality it's
nice to know what people mean by terms
those are some Bennie's right there I
guess you know if the Stoics are right
we have kind of Aristotle's right we
kind of innate as a ire to assumably the
distinctions that people have made could
be worth knowing about do you need to
know
exam you know you could do Aristotle and
never think about idealism and
materialism because that's not how
Aristotle actually coordinated his
thinking about things these are you know
they're sort of words that we associate
things under I guess they're useful when
you're when you're starting out learning
philosophy but you don't want to be too
wedded typical work is basically saying
is so-and-so an in determinist that's
really kind of boring
the interesting thing as well okay let's
say so-and-so isn't a determinist how
does it actually work what do they think
the will is how does it how do these
factors in pinja about it that's what
I'm always more interested in people
have asked me about a couple people here
Nick land edward resets haven't read
those those people so i don't know
anything about them Jessica asks could
you briefly describe the differences in
the conception of nothing between jewish
kaballa Buddhist cosmology
existentialism and vulgar conception no
I can't really do that as a matter of
fact I'm not qualified to talk about the
Jewish Kabbalah and or to generalize
about Buddhist cosmology I can say that
even just within existentialism Sartre
and Heidegger disagree about the nature
of the nothing and about you know sort
of how negation works and and so that
you know it's quite complicated it's
something eventually I do want to write
a book about a book about nothing how
she s how are the limits of my language
limits of my thoughts well you know you
don't have to be Vidkun Stein or rather
early Vidkun china to think that that
idea language conditions are our ways of
thinking you know it's it's not it may
not be that the limits of our language
or the limits of our thought and Vidkun
stein you know kind of backpedals on a
lot of these these these assertions
but you know it's pretty hard to follow
a thought through without using language
and and the language that we are working
with does condition it so that's
important Thomas asks what are some
ideas from philosophy people should know
in order to live flourishing lives well
I mean there's a whole slew of them I
mean let let's make it really simple you
got to figure out first of all what what
counts as flourishing right and so you
know there's a lot of different ways of
conceiving this Pete some people think
it's having a ton of money and you know
buying a lot of consumer goods and then
they try it and they find out that
they're not really happy because they
didn't work on their character and all
and they they're screwing everything up
with the money that they have some
people think that you know just
indulging in physical pleasure is gonna
really make them happy and they do that
then they get bored with it and you know
we can go on and on and on about that
but I would say that thinking about the
nature of what what actually counts is
flourishing that that's an important
starting point right and then you know
understanding what we mean by say habits
virtues vices that that's pretty
important as well a lot of it is being
able to make good distinctions well
here's a here's an interesting question
South Perry would you ever go to the
streets to question people about their
beliefs kind of like Socrates did so I
mean Socrates gives you that line but he
doesn't really like spend a lot of time
in the Agora talking with people you
read Plato's dialogues most of them take
place and houses or in you know like
like parks or things like that but it
didn't go around and ask people lots of
questions he did way more than that
because otherwise he would just be a nun
sufferable ass people who are going to
do Socratic questioning usually are just
you know they're really boring quite
frankly
because you can just keep on asking why
why why why why why why over and over
again and that isn't all that Socrates
does he actually does have some some
ideas about things and he tries to lead
people and to them would I ever do that
sort of thing I don't know I mean if
somebody gave me a show I guess but
again it's a question of time I get 24
hours a day just like everybody else
bended on that rather than on let's say
producing content or or things like that
um defect what do you think of living
philosophers like Molyneux I guess I
could consider millennia philosophers I
mean I'm willing to say that Rand is a
philosopher I you know I watched him
early on this is back when I was at FSU
and I was totally under impressed with
him and I don't really you know every
once in a while
I'll watch like a little bit of one of
his videos when somebody's posted
something and it's never changed my my
view there are some great living
philosophers Alistair McIntyre is still
alive you know I've been lucky enough
being involved with the modern stoicism
project to get to meet Chris Gill to get
to meet as Julianna's and Margaret
graver and at the upcoming stoic on I'm
gonna get to meet a law on these are
heavyweights these are people who have
made massive contributions to
understanding ancient philosophy you
know and getting to talk with them
that's great there there's a lot of
living philosophers out there who aren't
big you could say in the pop culture
field or in the YouTube verse that are
doing some really wonderful work and
thinking
all right there's a question from
somebody whose name is in in Chinese
characters which I only know like 200 of
them I carry this have you ever learned
Chinese philosophy why not come to China
together course one day so two good
questions
yes I used to teach Chinese philosophy
but not in an expert level I actually
have made a couple stabs at learning
Mandarin but never actually followed it
through effectively you know it's kind
of a downer for me what I can would I
come to China to think of course yeah
but I'd have to be invited yeah so so if
you if people are interested in that
they've got to send me an invitation and
make other arrangements but yes I'd
certainly be willing to do that sort of
thing I'd love to do that same thing
goes for anybody anywhere you want me to
come and give a talk email me you know I
give talks all over the place you want
me to come teach a course somewhere you
know get in touch with me about that all
right we're getting kind of close to
time taking these Linden what are some
of the important cultural components of
modern America that have their seeds in
religious thought or religious culture
well well you know there was that phrase
somebody had about the God haunted self
but the whole you know of America is God
wanted right and we have you know we
have like all these different
denominations and families that have
made their impact I mean it's kind of
funny even today you know atheists
complain about this pretty routinely
that it'd be very hard to run as an
atheist candidate for say president
although you know you look at that you
know quite a few of the presidents and
they may as well have been atheists
because whatever thin veneer of faith
that they have is is just bullet and and
had no impact whatsoever on their their
presidencies but it's very important
to appeal to that because there's
there's a lot of people take that quite
quite seriously I mean you know here in
America we have all these different
religious institutions and they do
affect quite a lot of aspects of our
life but you know many of them are kind
of falling down in their their religious
tasks you know I'll give you one prime
example it's really funny you know when
people talk about like Catholic colleges
and universities because most of them
are very barely Catholic and there's a
lot fun like sort of like divisions
within them like if you go to Notre Dame
University of Notre Dame
there's actually a guidebook for the
students that helps them to get an
authentically Catholic education because
they will not get it going to the
regular classes in the university you
gotta like go to this professor this
professor this professor avoid this one
avoid this one because there's been so
much hiring of people who are just you
know absolutely hostile to to any sort
of orthodoxy and this is the case in in
in many cases I've been told because I
do work on the Catholic intellectual
tradition those years back when I was
still in the job market
you're too Catholic to work at that
Catholic institution they'd never hire
you and I'm not particularly devout I
just happen to have written on blown
down and a quietness and people like
that so you know a lot of times these
religious institutions there are a lot
of you know real believers within them
but a lot of times the institutions
themselves are kind of hey what
everybody else does and they they gussy
it up with with kind of a religious
tinge to it and that's all too often the
case you know but you know it's it's the
sort of thing that you want to be
attuned to I guess
0fo Fi how does cert deal with choices
as related to the future he says the
future doesn't exist but is it now so
what about choices that depend on the
outcome of each other I mean read Being
and Nothingness and he sets it out in
great detail or read some of his novels
the future strictly speaking doesn't
exist that we we make choices and sight
doesn't believe that there isn't he it's
only like the eternal now or something
like that he just thinks that we're our
choices are dependent on the grounds
that we choose for making those choices
we exist in radical freedom as he says
you know but you know that the apparatus
for that there's there's a really good
discussion of that and being in
nothingness subconscious qualms is Marx
the greatest political theorist of all
time if not who is I don't think Marx is
the greatest political theorist a lot of
Marxist to right if I had to pick the
greatest political theorist of all times
that's a tough one
I mean so many people sort of like rise
up but they don't have all the all the
stuff that I'd want so I I don't know I
couldn't say I guess let's see Oh a
whole bunch of new questions here we're
getting closed then I'll go over a
little bit as I've done in the past
scrolling up a lot but here's one from
ferry should get it like I have a
patreon to help me financially all you
have to do is like type in you know
Sandler or patreon you're gonna find it
I'm not sure how you don't see it and
they're super chancy I be yeah you're
gonna set that I haven't done that I've
stream debating or having a conversation
with another person that takes some
doing you know I mean we all have things
that we like
having done live streams in the past
like that but I don't know that I'm
gonna do that at this point I already do
enough like podcast thing will shows up
like that if you follow me on I might
you know my website or or you know other
social media you'll probably hear a lot
about that stuff oh wow there's a lot
here people complaining about the
connection it's futile
you know you get what you get out of
that right Andrews got a great question
do you think knowledge is something that
can be completely gained from books or
as an interface teachers experience
record I think it's the latter I mean
some kinds of knowledge you can get from
books or courses or stuff like that but
others you you actually need you know
the thing I need some back and forth
with with practitioners who can help you
with it that's what at Thomas
to say about the Stoics this is from j2b
to Nick well that's interesting
so Thomas got the Stoics wrong in the
treatise on emotions he took the Stoics
as saying that all and as we know of
course that that's not the case it's
knowing to do view many emotional
responses as you know / to bait
perturbations I'm mangling the word of
the soul disturbances right and they do
think those are bad but they also
thought they were the good passions or
the good good emotions that you pathya
and I mean Thomas didn't get that does
he have to say about them I don't really
remember any other things coming to mind
but I'm not doing a lot of work on
Thomas lately so let's see scroll down a
bit here's an interesting one any
thoughts on bod you you know interesting
guy I haven't spent a lot of time
looking at his stuff my wife is actually
studied with him at eg asked and he
acted in his play there and she says
he's a great guy but you know it's not
somebody who I really have the time for
spending a lot of time on you know
unfortunately because I don't have that
much oh here's a great one for Michael
what philosophers do you dislike now
that in years past you enjoyed or agreed
with dislike
um I don't know that there's a thing I
dislike offhand alright I like went
through a phase and I've done videos
about that and you know I was like well
I gotta kind of leave this behind right
I went through a dairy death phase and
went through through a Vidkun Stein
phase and went through a niche buffets
oh yes there's a thing about the phase
that's a good sign that I disagree with
them because I'm no longer you're in
that phase sir hey probably that's
probably the best way to have to answer
it
see see what else we Paul ha ha ha ha ha
Jim powerful cardigan there yeah so this
is the this is the dude sweater right I
was getting all of these remarks yeah
you know when I used to wear my hair
down my hair was a bit shorter than -
and of course my beard wasn't wasn't
great on a lot of the earlier videos and
people like is the dude teaching
philosophy and so my wife got a real
kick out of that and then one Christmas
couple Christmases ago she bought me
this this sweater and I've worn it in
some places like you know going here and
in Milwaukee duckpin bowling and people
are all like wow look the dude is
bowling so yeah that's cool let's see
what else we have here
what if we gave all our very early
profits and extra labor or two huge
prolific projects that would ensure
humankind survival for 17,500 years that
would be pretty cool um I'm not at the
state age make actually devote yearly
profits to anything because I'm just
basically living doing what I do and I
don't have any extra labor time I
already give away a lot of stuff for
free like here
or the talks that I do or you know I do
some some pro bono work as well but you
know what it'd be good for other people
to do that yeah I mean it'd be wonderful
to see that sort of prescient rather
than you know people just saying screw
it I've got my money as they say devil
take the hindmost so let's - what else
you got here all Bismol you the minute
or so there's a little story there
there's the who's who's the they they're
the people on fortune and they coined
the phrase the Minotaur of Milwaukee and
you'd have to ask them precisely why a
that came up there's there's a picture
of me out there well colleague of friend
and colleague of mine recently sent me a
like a super super long screenshot of
like a long thread talking about the the
videos and there's one where it's
actually from a very old video of mine
that I did back at Fayetteville State
University and they put like a Minotaur
head-on on top of my my body I guess
it's because I'm a really big guy and
maybe I'm bullish and in some some way I
don't know oh here's a good one from
Sammy who what is the school of
philosophy that has influenced you the
most I guess if you he had to say in
general like across the board who's been
most influential on me it'd be Aristotle
probably but you know he would not be
very far ahead of say the Stoics and
Plato and various Christian authors and
existentialists all kind of
neck-and-neck
I know it might change too as I get
older there was an interesting one from
canal why do people without any or very
little formal education become so
popular on YouTube in the philosophy
sphere at the site mainly thinking of
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris etc well I
mean Jordan Peterson
so we want to be careful right so Jordan
Peterson's degree is in psychology but
that doesn't mean that he hasn't studied
philosophy I mean you you study
philosophy probably as an undergraduate
and there's plenty of overlap between
philosophy and other fields so I had me
sort of like you know if we say about a
historian well they don't have a
philosophy degree so they're not
entitled to talk about philosophy well
to begin with philosophy is the kind of
field where we actually don't see jerks
there there are plenty of academic jerks
that way but you know a lot of
philosophy actually gets done outside of
philosophy departments and you know
clearly he's and thought quite a bit
about Nietzsche so you know am Harris I
don't know that much about to be able to
say that way I the bit of stuff that
I've read I haven't been impressed with
[Music]
but why do people all a lot of you know
it's called philosophical training and
depth become popular on YouTube oh it's
because it's easy for them to get a big
focus with Molyneux right you just stake
out a strong position without not a hell
of a lot of new ones and just keep
hammering away at that and you're gonna
get a lot more viewers and subscribers
than people like me who are being very
careful to present things accurately and
you know when well yes but no that's
much less dramatic I think most most
people watching stuff on YouTube would
love to have simple answers because
that's the way it isn't in the rest of
the world right and what we try to do is
we numb away from that is the best we
can and I don't like to you know go in
and and say well here's the whole
systematic thing you know I want to say
I'm doing a presentation at a business I
often don't even tell them the stuff
that I'm doing isn't just doing straight
management theory and is actually coming
from say Aristotle but you know it's uh
you see this sort of thing all the time
coming up I mean the good thing is that
down the line the people who are just
doing popular stuff there they're not
going to be around for 20 years 30 years
you reading them and referencing their
works except us careful you know more
historically grounded people robbed an
elder I've been reading the Stoics and
came across your channel via stoic on I
liked the content but there's a huge
amount of it any tips on where to start
I've been watching the intro to
philosophy lectures well there is a
search function in YouTube so if you
want to see stuff on Aristotle type in
Sadler Aristotle right and that'll come
up or or sadler stoicism there's also
playlists so if you're interested in the
stoicism stuff you know we go to the
stoicism playlist now granted there's
you know over a hundred videos and that
but you know you can sort of pick
through them YouTube doesn't organize
stuff in an easy to follow paths but you
know I don't know really what to tell
you about that it's up to the viewer to
decide what they want to what they want
to go through I mean if you want to
organize sort of a course of self-study
I do that through my tutorial services
but that's something I do individually
with with clients pyrole I asked you
this yesterday and you already gave me a
brief answer but how do i best use the
half hour Hegel series if my native
language is German I mean we talked
about what translations you know to get
and you got to watch them in English
because I don't I don't I don't do it in
German so I don't really know what to
tell you yeah beyond that you know I do
have some German viewers and actual
patreon supporters of it but yeah
would you recommend to live as an
epicurean or as historic I'm actually an
eclectic I I draw on stoicism as well as
on you know Aristotelian ISM and a
number of different things I would say
what I would recommend is read widely in
both traditions and then arrive at a
decision for yourself an informed
decision so you know I mean I I'm if I
choose epicurean its stoicism but
there's more than just that as the
options you know here's a funny one and
from defect Buddha versus the Jesus in a
knife fight who would win all of us
because they wouldn't fight so Pullman
have you have you done considered doing
videos on Senecas letters yes that is
something that I want to do and I'll
actually eventually be building online
course content on that as well but it's
a matter of again I need to do that oh
this is a great one Steven to what
extent was post-modernism an trishal and
vital for throwing off certain kinds of
dogma elitism and unquestioning sheep
dub well that's a loaded question if I
ever saw one right
pulled honors it means a lot of
different things I think most people who
talk about post-modernism don't have a
clue about what it means they've gotten
some sort of watered down version which
has very little connection to what we
actually talked about it's postmodern
post-modernism by the way the way the
postmodern is talked about isn't it
tension of modernism is it absolutely
crucial and vital for throwing out
certain kinds of dogma no I mean that's
part of the modern project the whole
enlightenment project is in part about
throwing off that sort of stuff and you
should also not see modernism or
enlightenment as just one thing you know
I've got a great essay back as a
graduate student called Hegel or the
second enlightenment Hey there's there's
various forms of that so I mean and you
don't actually need that
in order to throw off those things but
if reading each it helps you with that
great you know all right I'm gonna skip
down a bit and start getting close to
wrapping this up ooh here's a good one
from AC e do you believe ambition is
more of a destructive trait or something
to embrace both it's more of a
destructive trait the way most people
seem to handle ambition but it is also
something that we ought but embrace
rightly which means developing a proper
understanding of ambition making sense
of it within an ethical framework so
there's limits on it there's there's
lines we're not going to cross same
thing goes with you know self-promotion
there was a interesting discussion along
shameless self-promotion and whether
academics ought to engage in it and my
answer was let's use Aristotle toddlers
stand this the good one from flea-bitten
do you think Heidegger was right when he
said we've reached the end of philosophy
no I don't think so um that said I think
that we ought to spend a lot more time
you know engaging with past philosophy
and each generation has to sort of
rediscover it and new and reinterpret it
but I think there's there's you know
there's advances there's there's there's
newer stuff so anti Rights was Derry
down Antichrist seems that's a common
Western stance I think that would be
raiding dear great afar to make him into
an antichrist
maybe you mean an anti-christian or
something like that and the answer would
be no they're actually like working at
different different directory dies late
work by the way you're gonna see
religion playing a very important role
in that even like discusses you know
Kierkegaard and the Gospels if the gift
of death right so no and and Derrida I
think
Derrida is one of these thinkers - Wow
probably only gonna be read by
specialists III don't think he's gonna
have a lot of staying power I think
Foucault will have more but even
Foucault you know in many respects we're
gonna say well I was wrong about this
he's wrong about this this is an
interesting idea but there this is
underdeveloped or or this is you know
this is whose schematic you know let's
see here
Oh drowning in decimals what is your
favorite approach in to the classroom so
oh I like the classroom to be integrated
with what we call a course management
and I teach you know online from Marist
occasionally and I used to teach
face-to-face for them as well
I build out a course site and actually
you can access some of these on the
reason IO Academy
you know I offer them very few of them
for free some of them for you know very
affordable prices compared to what you
normally pay for college classes at
institution but I like to generate like
an entire thing that has you know lesson
pages handouts worksheets lecture videos
you know if it's an online if it's a you
know four credit class you know
assignments rubrics all these sorts of
things things and so the idea is what
you're doing in the classroom is just an
extension of what you're doing in the
course site and you know I I would also
video record my love extra to there are
newer ones from Marist and then their
resources for people and so the idea is
to get students to spend and instead of
just spending tuning off hours and the
class asharam a next of the week if I
can get them like maybe ten hours a week
a lot more learning takes place and it
sticks with them a lot longer so yeah um
Oh
jumped down on a whole bunch again so it
looks like a lot of they've come in do
there's a good one Nicholas McCall is it
just meteors is Aristotle more relevant
to contemporary philosophy than Plato
MacIntyre and others all seem to prefer
him it is you MacIntyre and Saul says
that Plato is very important and and
there is a whole Platonic tradition
Plato doesn't end with Plato Plato
continues on through middle Platonism
like Plutarch who doesn't just write
biographies he writes all these moral
treatises and then into neoplatonism
which then you know influences
Christianity MacIntyre is more of an
Aristotelian than a plate inist
but he does does think that was
incredibly important so you know you see
one of things about say Giuliana's right
so that that's a good one beuse we got
here Merrill wolf why should we take
Bertrand Russell with a grain of salt we
don't have to but if you read Russell in
his history of philosophy and then read
the people who he's talking about you'll
see that he's a pretty poor historian of
philosophy mister representing things oh
you know like anybody who tends to
misrepresent things should you take them
at their word I don't know if you have a
girlfriend
it misrepresents people to you should
you believe them when they talk about
that sort of thing probably not right so
yeah
doo-doo-doo-doo let's see
we're of the philosophical school of
traditionalism that is thinkers like
rene guenon mayer que le odd julius
Cavallo I'm aware the sir off the bat
I'm aware of the original school of
traditionalism the traditional
traditionalists who would be the people
coming out out of critique of the in the
in the nineteenth century like Joseph de
my stand de bon old and lawmen may dance
with traditionalism originally meant so
already we've got a traditionalism
that's not quite as traditional right
and and le odd knows some of these
people by the way I'm totally odd in in
in classes I don't teach him as a
traditionalist but I teach him as a
decent you know phenomenologist and
theorist about religion and yeah I'm
aware of the philosophical school of it
I haven't spent much time reading the
other the other people involved in it
and I don't I don't know if I will that
you know they're they're interesting so
or here's a good one and I know that
that there's 4chan people who are who
are listening to this what is from I am
viewing your videos what do you think of
4chan so you know it's it's an
interesting sites you know sort of like
reddit I don't know enough about it to
make it actually usable for me
and I don't really have the time to scan
it but I have people who send shots from
it every so often and every once in a
while I'll like google sandler 4chan to
see if some some you know particularly
crazy stuff came up and it's interesting
because there's such a free flow of
conversation there and people you know
like post there's of me and and come up
with stories so there there's a lot of
interesting imaginative work or going on
there but it's one of those sort of
things where I I guess I don't really
get it and I'm not saying that that that
reduces its value again like right I
don't really get reddit you
I stick to the stuff that I understand
better because again I only had so much
time so yeah but I'm you know I'm glad
that that they're interested in in my
work they usually say nice things about
my stuff some of them you know get get
on me for being fat or being old or or
various other things you know but you're
always getting at people criticizing you
for different stuff all right
there's a good question from Rayanne
what do you think is the best way to
approach the works of Aristotle I've
every read I've already read quite a few
philosophers but he seems a lot there's
no easy entry book into Aristotle you
know it's like with stoicism you could
start somebody off with a few of Senecas
letters and the epictetus and Marcus
Aurelius meditations sorry there or like
Plato oh you know let's start some of
the earlier dialogues right then we're
not gonna do the Republic right away
there is no like easy book by Aristotle
um Wow how do people start people off
with the categories that's what an
Aristotle and I you know already by
chapter two I was like what the hell is
this crap understand what at least okay
I'm actually developing an online class
which should be I should be releasing
later this month on Aristotle's
categories trying to help people out
with that because it is so confusing I
mean here's here's what I would say
either astana like read the Nicomachean
ethics read the politics read the
rhetoric you know read the works that
they call the organ on as far you know
read the metaphysics read that on the
soul but but each time that you approach
it don't expect to get a hell of long
I'll sort of that the and as time goes
on you'll start to kind of see how the
picture fits together
- if you don't have Greek because
there's a lot of times we're like one
term this is how I got so interest in an
Aristotle on angry here one term may be
used in one way in one translation and
then the same term is used it's it means
something different in another
translation it's the same term but if
you don't let's see the Greek it's hard
to turn I'd be that so
Oh I'll mention - I've got a ton of
videos on Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics
and on the categories to do a lot of
people arguing back and forth about
Aleister Crowley used to have a student
who's always trying to get you know push
him on me when I was in the prison it
was really big on that let's see we got
anonymous I have found plato's opinions
in Plato's Republic to be an argue for
an authoritarianism have I misread
Plato's Republic yeah to some degree
remember the Republic is an ideal city
that's being sketched out it's not
plato's a blueprint you might want to go
and look at the laws as another sort of
counterpoint to that and you could you
know there's authoritarianism and
authoritarianism right it's not always
the same there is a class structure with
this kind of a purpose to that it's not
just well these guys happen to have
power so everyone should listen to them
Plato disposes of that in book 1 with
through Simic Asst right that might
makes right theory so yeah yeah I you
probably want to go back to it and read
it again Robert
different philosophers have had
different ideas of how to respond to the
absurd when one confronts the absurd
what do you believe is the best approach
to bad faith or philosophical suicide so
you know this is this is one of those
things where ideas evolved if you look
at what's going on in myth the symphysis
and then later writings like letters to
a German front you know the ramble or
you know other other things along those
lines or the characters and is later
later now there's a lot of other
possible reactions to to the absurd and
a new issues that that are bra maybe
it's a mistake to generalize as much as
Camus did and the mythos if Issus about
the absurd you know Simone de Beauvoir
said it's not an absurd life it's an
ambiguous one
Gabrielle Marcel said well a lot of
things are absurd but there's lost
illogical mystery so it's not something
that you you necessarily want to take as
as absolutely given but an even Camus
presents it is well this is how I see it
you know all right
why is human shaped like a potato
because he ate a lot they got fat you
know though here's a good one from from
random guy we're gonna a half an hour
beyond the hour that I scheduled for
this our self-help books discount
philosophy some are the better won't
actually do the better self-help books
our philosophy put into a popular
framework the worst ones are
even close to the level of philosophy
they're just drivel you know the same
thing about management theory edie
theory Lada has watered-down philosophy
of one form or another so what happened
here let's see here
Lorenzo asks did I start with the Greeks
no I started in a totally haphazard way
of just kind of reading stuff and I
didn't just read stuff that was
philosophy I was an avid reader when I
was when I was a kid you know and that
continued on and when I took philosophy
classes they were usually not very good
when I was in undergraduate even
graduate school a lot of them were not
particularly great and I just been read
and read and read I did not start in any
sort of sequential way I read who I felt
like reading a lot of times you know who
I wanted to read I would look at the
people whom them and if I thought that
person was a jerk I wouldn't bother to
read that person that was being
recommended if I thought that the person
had something on the ball I'd take a
look at it I don't recommend that that's
I don't recommend that as a way of doing
things people always ask me who should I
start with I always say start with
playdough
you know but you can start philosophy
wherever you want you just might find it
less productive to like try to begin you
know the 20th century but you know one
of the things to remember is you're
never gonna read everybody so you got to
pick what you're going to to folk is
[Music]
pick one last question to end with and a
lot of questions here that I'm not
getting to so I apologize for not
getting to everybody's questions but you
know the longer that I do this the more
questions are piling up and
oh here's a good one matheus what do you
think of the problem of evil I think
that it's it's a really important thing
to try to come to terms with but it's
important to try to do it in a sort of
good faith not dismissing things because
you've got a sort of an emotional
attachment to this or this or you know
way and you want to read what people
have read about it throughout the course
of history because there's a lot of
smart people who've said some really
interesting things about that I will say
this that I think that Gabrielle Marcel
is right that the problem of evil is in
some respect miss named as the problem
of evil and it's really the mystery of
evil something that we need to adopt a
different frame of reference towards and
if you want to you know learn about that
getting is a little book the philosophy
of existentialism which it's out of
refined used copies online very cheaply
and it's also in a lot of used
bookstores this is well worth reading
you know that's it for today we're
already at 1:32 I have another thing I
got to do at 2 o'clock and I've got some
other work I've got to get to pretty
soon thanks for all of your really great
croisé anybody who decides if they want
to support this kind of work you can go
to patreon.com/scishow to be a tree and
supporters you guys are really helping
me out with this sort of thing and we'll
do one of these every month going
forward you can see the old ones there's
I think they're in one of my playlists
and they did a blog entry about it
recently that's pretty much it
have a great for those of you on this
continent have a great afternoon
or end of the morning if you're really
far for West those of you in in your
Europe and Africa and
you know the Middle East have a great
evening or night time those of you in
you know much further east and Australia
Japan places like that and a great
morning no not yet
have a great eight middle of the night
next day a yeah yeah we'll call it a to
an end right here